bienvenidos nuevamente acabamos de
encontrar cuánto tiempo le llevó a esto
mantenerse en el aire y caer qué podemos
hacer con esto bueno vamos a limpiar un
poco la pantalla ok
voy a dibujar esto tratando de que se
vea un poquito más elegante
entonces bueno tenemos que
lanzamos
nuestra pelota
unos
10 metros por segundo
en un ángulo de 45 grados
nuestros conforman el tiempo nuestros
componentes perdón nuestros componentes
verticales y horizontales de este vector
y aquí más o menos
con este elemento
y nuestro componente
vertical
más o menos explica kim
rivas bueno más o menos
encontramos que los valores
de la velocidad vertical
eran igual a 10 por el seno de 45 grados
que es igual a 5 por raíz de 2
metros por segundo de la misma manera
encontramos que nuestra velocidad
horizontal es igual a 10 por el coseno
de 45 grados
que resultó también igual a 5 por la
raíz de 2 al cuadrado metros por segundo
bueno para saber el tiempo que tarda en
el aire tomamos la componente vertical y
dijimos que bueno cuánto tiempo si
lanzáramos esto hacia arriba
cuánto tiempo le tomaría
de una velocidad inicial igual a 5 por
raíz de 2 metros por segundo llegar a
una velocidad final igual a cero
usamos el cambio de velocidad y nos
quedó que
menos 5 por raíz de 2
era igual a menos 10 que nuestra verdad
o nuestra desaceleración metros por
segundo al cuadrado por el tiempo
despejamos el tiempo y nos quedó
resolviendo esto que el tiempo era igual
a raíz de dos segundos
y bueno quedamos en que el mismo tiempo
que les lleva en subir es el mismo
tiempo que le lleva de partir desde cero
hasta volver a acelerar y que era el
suelo entonces
nuestro tiempo total
en el que tardó en subir y bajar
es el doble de este tiempo que
encontramos entonces es 2 por raíz de 2
segundos podemos usar esto para saber
qué tan lejos llegó la piel a la pelota
bueno todo el trabajo anterior lo
hicimos sobre la componente vertical
pero el tiempo que la pelota subía y
bajaba es el mismo tiempo que le tomo
moverse de izquierda a derecha en la
componente con una velocidad horizontal
vamos a asumir que la velocidad
horizontal se mantiene constante porque
hacemos esta asunción bueno primero
porque asumimos que no hay resistencia
al aire ya que la resistencia al aire
complica mucho los cálculos y si es algo
pequeño con una piedra o una moneda pues
casi no tiene resistencia al aire y si
no hay aire que pueda detener el
movimiento en la componente horizontal
pues nada la gravedad sólo actúa de
manera horizontal jalando nos hacia
abajo se pueden imaginar empujando algo
sobre el hielo y no habrá manera que
algo lo detenga ni la fricción y la
resistencia del aire lo que lo mantiene
en movimiento
las suposiciones que hacemos serían
totalmente correctas en la luna donde o
en algún lugar donde no haya aire
bueno entonces todo el tiempo que le
llevó la pelota a subir y bajar también
estuvo moviéndose a la derecha a una
velocidad constante de 5 x raíz cuadrada
metros por segundo
cual cuánto tiempo se mantuvo moviéndose
a la derecha como vimos pues se mantuvo
en el aire y acabamos de calcular este
tiempo entonces
tenemos que la diferencia en la
distancia
horizontal pues es muy sencilla es igual
a la velocidad promedio por el tiempo
cada vez que vamos a decir que la
velocidad promedio pues es una velocidad
constante así que es igual a la que
calculamos en la componente horizontal 5
x raíz cuadrada de 2 metros por segundo
y el tiempo que es el tiempo que
calculamos
nuestro tiempo
qué es raíz de 2 segundos
entonces bueno multiplicamos la idea dos
por otra raíz de dos se quita esta raíz
de dos nos queda dos y multiplicamos
perdón es 2
porque estoy usando el tiempo total aquí
ya me estaba equivocando nuestro tiempo
total es 2 x raíz de 2 entonces y
resolviendo esto nos queda 5 por 2 10
raíz de 2 por raíz de 2 nos quede igual
a 2
y esto es igual a
20 metros
esto es genial todo lo que hice fue usar
estos datos de mi componente de vertical
y mi componente horizontal para
encontrar este resultado podemos hacer
lo opuesto y lo vamos a hacer en
problemas posteriores de encontrar cuál
es el ángulo óptimo si queremos lanzar
algo por ejemplo a tres kilómetros de
distancia y estarían resolviendo este
mismo problema así que no es nada tan
difícil de hacer podemos conocer otros
datos de este problema como por ejemplo
qué tan alto llegó la pelota
entonces vamos a reescribir nuestros
datos en otro color para agregarle
variedad
bueno la altura o la distancia la
diferencia de distancia vertical me va a
involucrar la velocidad promedio pero
bueno esta es la velocidad de el
componente en la velocidad vertical
promedio una variable un poco rara
y esta es igual a bueno nuestra
velocidad inicial fue 5 raíz cuadrada de
2 nuestra velocidad final fue 0 y esto
para sacar el promedio lo tenemos que
sumar y dividir entre 2 lo que nos queda
con 5
raíz de 2 entre 2
y bueno esto lo usamos en nuestra
fórmula de la distancia
vertical es igual a la velocidad
promedio por el tiempo nuestra velocidad
promedio de 5 raíz de 2 / 2
por el tiempo
por el tiempo que les llevó llegar a
esta distancia
máxima que es la mitad de nuestro
periodo y es por raíz de 2 entonces
esto lo despejamos y nos queda que la
diferencia en distancia pero lo
resolvemos la diferencia en distancia
nos queda igual a 5 metros
bueno en el siguiente vídeo resolveremos
esto de una manera más general y vamos a
resolverlo de la manera opuesta si nos
dan los datos de altura y tiempo qué
velocidad encontraríamos que fue la
velocidad inicial para clarificar un
poco este resultado vamos a dibujar
nuevamente qué bueno lanzamos
nuestra
pelota
a 10 metros por segundo
aquí en este punto más alto llegó a los
5 metros
y la distancia que le llevó a subir y
bajar años
20 metros
esta distancia
entonces si dibujáramos cuál fue la
trayectoria de nuestra pelota pues
tomamos que la lanzamos aquí
subió subió subió llegó a la altura
máxima y bajó bajó bajo hasta que pudo
llego al suelo
bueno nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo